il ya eu cette nouvelle allocution du
président céline ski tout à l'heure
cette fois le président ukrainien s'est
adressé au parlement norvégien le pays
fournit près de 25% du gaz consommé par
les européens et des britanniques
écoutez volodine arensky
vous êtes le fournisseur d'énergie le
plus fiable au monde et nous vous avons
toujours accordé toute notre confiance
et votre comportement est complètement
différent de celui de la russie dans sa
politique énergétique
vous pouvez donc apporté une
contribution décisive dans la sécurité
énergétique de l'europe en fournissant
les ressources nécessaires aux pays de
l'union européenne et à l'ukraine